all right people we are live on the
youtube i am post off the grid dave
rubin it's september 3rd 2021 this is
the reuben report direct message and as
you guys know we usually do the panel
show on fridays but because i was off
the grid and i'm just trying to catch up
on so much of what's been going on i
want to do something a little bit
different today so glenn beck who of
course needs no introduction
will be joining us for the full half
hour solo and we're really going to
focus on afghanistan do a little bit of
timeline what's going on now a little
bit of the media reaction to it and
quite a bit on his nazarene fund which
has raised i just checked this with his
people right before we started an
incredible
35 million that's 35 million dollars to
help get christian refugees out of
afghanistan who are under the threat of
death and torture and and all sorts of
bad stuff uh so glenn has done something
really incredible work travel to the
middle east in the midst of all this
we'll talk about all of that and really
i wanted to do this because as i'm
catching up on afghanistan in real time
uh i wanted to talk to somebody who i
think could give me sort of a full
breath of what's gone on there uh and a
sort of holistic look at all of this
because you know i'm trying to piece
together everything and watching videos
but you know the narrative changes over
time and i want to be as as clear and
clean with you guys on this as i
possibly can be all right so i'm going
to bring in glenn about 30 seconds but
before i do that i want to talk to you
guys about about black rifle coffee you
know black rifle coffee is a
veteran-owned coffee company serving
premium coffee to people who love
america they develop their explosive
roast profiles with the same mission
focus they learned as military members
serving this great country and are
committed to supporting veterans law
enforcement and first responders with
every purchase you make they give back
in 2020 they donated over six
million cups of coffee to veteran law
enforcement and first responder causes
black rifle coffee company imports high
quality coffee beans from columbia and
brazil and roasts five days a week at
their facilities in manchester tennessee
and salt lake city utah the best way to
enjoy the freedom-fueled coffee is by
subscribing to the black rifle coffee
club when you join the club your chosen
brew is roasted packaged and shipped
free to your door on your schedule not
only do you save a trip to the store you
see you receive a special discounted
pricing on various roasts and gain
access to exclusive products member-only
content partner discounts and more i got
to tell you always get excited when i
see a new bag has arrived and i promise
you these things are freaking huge i
also got this pretty cool mug from them
too with temperatures cooling off don't
let that stop you from getting outside
and into the great outdoors with
signature roasts like lava panther
medium roast which black rifle coffee
company directly sources farm to cup
from a small farm in guatemala black
rifle coffee company delivers fresh
roasted coffee from around the world
directly to your doorstep purchase at
blackriflecoffee.com reuben and use code
ruben at checkout for 20 off your
purchase including your first coffee
club order that's
blackriflecoffee.comruben and now back
to me i'm bringing in glenn beck glenn
you're a pro at pretty much everything
you do but you're an ad pro how did i
how did i do justin oh that was stunning
i don't even drink coffee and i've i've
already ordered some
so stunning
uh glenn it's great to see you my friend
um you know obviously i did this month
off the grid and you know you've brought
me back on uh i believe two years ago
you did that
so you know sort of
this month that i take off it's it's the
real deal
you know i've been waiting
i've been waiting uh for this day i i
got up this morning uh forgetting
honestly that we were even on today uh
and i could because i couldn't wait to
hear your reaction after vacation and i
heard adam and i'm like no adam don't
tell him like that no no no you're
missing this isn't that uh but yeah i i
can't imagine
what it must have felt like and i was
fascinated dave if we can i don't mean
to just hijack the show here but i was
fascinated i was fascinated by your
reaction and it at first i thought wow
that's a weird reaction and i thought no
it's not that's exactly what i would i
think i would be saying because your
reaction from the very beginning was
twofold each time he would tell you
something you go wait so
the taliban is in control now of
afghanistan you would restate what you
just uh said would just heard and then
you would say what is the press's
reaction to it
and i thought
that is a really really sad state of
affairs when when that is the primary
question
and i thought wow that's weird of dave
to say that and it i kept listening to
you and i kept thinking about it and i
thought no that is probably the most
important question because that's what
is controlling
public opinion that's what will set
whether or not
you know the people who were responsible
for this get away with it or not
it's the lens that matters more in a
sick twisted way than what actually
happened and actually that's precisely
why i wanted to have you on because i
watched a couple of your videos that
you've done in the last two weeks or so
about afghanistan and i obviously want
to talk about the nazarene fund i mean
it's it's truly like it's flooringly
incredible what you've done um but i
thought maybe we could just start um not
you know obviously most of my audience
has been playing along with this the
whole time but for people that haven't
or for people that just want you know me
to be part of this conversation can you
just give a couple minute explanation
of the timeline of what happened and
then and then we'll kind of get into the
optics part and and what's happening
right now so let me just give you really
from 40 000 feet um
there have been two people who have been
against these wars that has been joe
biden
and donald trump both of them
not for these wars joe biden is
constantly wrong historically if you
look it up on his positions almost every
time when it comes to foreign policy he
is diametrically opposed to the right
thing
um but we all agreed that we should get
out by the time donald trump was saying
this he was he was in the zeitgeist and
yeah we all want to get out the question
is how do you get out
um and you know there were there was no
one dying and i don't want an endless
war but it's not necessarily bad to keep
you know quote unquote peacekeepers to
keep people who are uh like we have in
germany et cetera et cetera
so
biden comes in they both have the same
goal but donald trump when he is
negotiating with the taliban which i
hated when he was negotiated when they
killed somebody
uh he bombed them stopped the
negotiation and killed them uh and so
that set a different precedent you know
it was like don't screw with the united
states we'll talk to you but
don't screw with us that was the
opposite approach of what joe biden uh
said now joe biden has been saying for
the long time that there's not going to
be any problems the the the pentagon is
all for it they're with it that's not
true as it turns out now we know that's
not true
he called president ghani who turned out
to be a i th i think a weasel
but
he called president ghani back in july i
think and said look this is starting to
look bad even if it's not true
you need to say
that things are going well and i don't
want to say that he was telling him to
lie
what he was saying was world perception
and even your own perception if you
present weakness you're going to you're
going to get back in spades i wish he
would take his own advice
but he then he knew at that time we know
now that the pentagon was saying this is
not good this is not going to go well
but for some reason joe biden just would
not
take no for an answer and i think it was
the political calculation of i want this
to end
uh and i believe it's going to go well
because i say it's going to go well and
i'm not changing course and it was an
absolute does that it was like
for about three days it was like
watching
um the
the planes fly into the world trade
center uh except it was in slower motion
it was it's that bad
um our allies were freaked out
joe biden i don't know if you know this
yet joe biden
wouldn't take a phone call or place a
phone call to the prime minister of
england for 40 hours
let me just pause for one sec since i am
playing a little catch up here were the
first when the images started coming out
was that the first time that the public
knew that the withdrawal was happening
or were they saying oh it's happening 24
hours oh they're saying they're saying
that uh it's happening and we were
pulling out of places and the taliban
was just sweeping it was just they were
just march it we'd leave
and they would march into the city and
the afghan um the afghan army would just
run surrender
um
so it was not going well
when they got to kabul they were even
surprised how fast they got to kabul
uh and
we needed the city to be secure because
our embassy our billion-dollar embassy
was sitting there
and
our pentagon and joe biden got the call
from the taliban and they said look
we're at the edge of the city it appears
as though president ghani has run
so
you either have to secure the city or we
will
so your two choices are come back and
secure the city while you do your
departure or we'll secure the city uh
and the airport gates but you secure the
airport that's the one we chose
well as soon as that happened uh it was
it was over everybody knew that taliban
was coming in and going to take control
there was no holding back
you know i know you saw that um that
video of the plane taking off i don't
know if you know that
uh
one of the guys that was in it was the
hero soccer player of the afghani uh
team
uh is so so desperate to get out and i
believe he was frozen
in one of the the wheel hubs um
the they said that after that plane
landed they needed to have psychiatrists
uh and and mental health officials on
the tarmac not for the people on the
plane but for the people who greeted the
plane because there were so many body
parts and things frozen and it it
dave it was
it was horrendous
so then we go into a place to where the
c-141s are loading up uh but
there's nobody saving you know the sivs
there's nobody looking out for the
little girls for the christians at this
point is when i say on the air we have
to do something i talked to the nazarene
fund they said it'll take at least 20
million dollars to get the
anywhere from 10 to 15 000 christians
out that are marked for death uh and we
didn't know how we were even going to do
it and 20 million dollars was a
ridiculous sum of money
and we started on wednesday by by friday
morning uh we had 25 million
raised just from my audience in hundreds
and tens and and it's crazy
and we were at the time just going to
rescue
christians because at that time we were
being told we won't leave anyone behind
i didn't see any way that that could be
done by august 31st but i was hoping
because
america doesn't leave people behind
and and there was a huge shift and this
is something that you you missed and it
was it was really good there was a huge
shift in i think the american psyche
uh during that week where
people were tired of being told they
can't do something and this was a big
thing and
by god they were going to do something
and
people and organizations from all over
sprung into action while we were having
fights with our british counterparts
while the french
were letting their people go through the
gates to go out and save their people
we were
we were just i i feel for everybody who
was wearing an american uniform on the
tarmac because i know
they wanted to go on the other side of
the gate and go get people but biden
wouldn't do it
do you see this then i mean from from
the side of trying to catch up on all
this everything that i have read it
seems like an abject disaster across the
board like it doesn't seem like there
was a moment it seems like they made a
decision and it simply did not matter
even despite those images which
basically couldn't have been more
horrific and then after what you just
described on the plane the planes landed
they continue to call it a success all
the way through
it's a success that is the craziest
stuff i've ever heard that's 25th
amendment stuff that man's clearly
delusional he's out of his mind um but
he refuses to call it anything else no
one is being held responsible for it
nobody's even being asked to step up and
be held responsible they gave away
bagram air force base why would we do
that and if we did do that we should
have bombed the tarmac so china or
others couldn't use it what did what
what were we thinking
in essence we've just armed the taliban
is that fair to say i mean with the
amount of stuff that we left there and
left the airfield we have now armed the
taliban
now you can say and this is partly true
i think it's unreasonable to believe
i think it's unreasonable to think that
there wasn't a
uh a
in case they take over and lose all
these things here's what we're going to
do to make sure they don't have all
these weapons um they they just say that
happened because we didn't expect the
afghani forces just to abandon but
that's not true we know from that uh
phone call joe biden made in july he
said looks like your guys are just
giving up and that cannot be
and so we didn't do air support we did
nothing and when they left they just
picked up all the gun 16 000
night vision goggles
the reason why that's important is
because we can actually
paint people
on the ground and we know we paint them
and then the drone or whoever knows
exactly that's the target and they had
no idea because they couldn't see the
paint
now they have 16 000 of these and you
don't think russia is paying for some of
those you don't think china's paying for
some of those this is
this is i think i think this is
the most impeachable thing i have i've
seen in my lifetime and that includes
nixon
i mean the sad truth though of course is
that there won't be any impeachment
because of this and there there probably
won't even be anyone fired or any maybe
somebody some you know third-rate person
gets blamed for something one of the
things that you mentioned the media part
of this when when adam was explaining
this all to me i asked him about the
initial reaction from the media and he
said that the images of the planes and
the people falling off and all that was
so shocking and happening in real time
that there was a small window basically
where the media was actually like you
know kind of calling out the
administration and everything else yeah
how do you think the media has done sort
of subsequently from that
poorly um you know they did there
yeah they did their they did their deal
and now they're off it and i can tell
you uh dave if you would have plugged
back in and not had a briefing
and you would have come back in probably
tuesday or wednesday of next week it
would be like this didn't happen yeah
because i think this story is now over
there
you can feel it already even just from
your questions i'm trying not to be on
twitter too much but on a quick scroll
it's kind of like that's not really what
we're talking you know it's all back to
covid's stuff here yeah it's yeah it's
it's it's
and and we have left
thousands behind thousands behind it is
this is one of the worst moral injuries
to our nation and especially to our
troops i've ever seen there is something
about america we don't turn in our
neighbors we we trust people that's what
people always say when they come here
you know you americans are just so
trusting yeah because we've never turned
on each other you know we never we never
called the kgb and said i think they're
doing this
um
but we also had this same
thing that we're pursuing we were we all
believed we were pursuing a more perfect
nation that believed in
equal rights and we didn't it's sloppy
and we didn't get it right but we were
making progress on many many fronts um
and
then all of a sudden that fell apart and
and now we're sitting here
uh
with this moral injury that all of us i
think all of us had and that is
we don't leave people behind we you know
we we don't leave
we don't we we left a guy
he's he we've been trying i guess to
negotiate for his release
he's just like a gas man he was over
there helping them build and and uh you
know take care of some stuff
he's was kidnapped in 2020. joe biden
said we're not going to leave without
him i don't think they even negotiated
for him we still don't have him we have
what 20 or no 40 students
from california that are still trapped
there what the hell do you mean the
united states military is leaving
no
no we don't leave people behind and
that's a huge
moral injury on all of us does this all
feel like just another extension of
everything else that seems wrong with
sort of this country and i think in a
broader sense the west at the moment
that nothing is working the way it's
supposed to every single institution
educational now military obviously
political they all are not functioning
so in a weird way it's like well how
could the united states leave in a
proper way because look who's in charge
and in a weird way it almost feels
intentional i mean that was my feeling
when i started catching up that the
disaster i don't think these people like
america that much i'm talking about our
leaders and i don't think they're that
embarrassed i think you're embarrassed i
think most americans are embarrassed
i think you're right yeah i think you're
right dave i think you know i've thought
about this a lot you know how do these
people sleep at night and how could you
i mean i couldn't plan a bigger disaster
i really couldn't i mean everything
right
and so that's wild incompetence but even
if you're that incompetent once in a
while something will fall in your favor
you know this this feels like it was
designed by people who hate america and
what i thought about when i was thinking
that was
um
you know we're looking at this and
saying how could we leave these people
behind but the people who are really in
charge the i mean the radicals now that
democrats i hope are waking up going
that's not the party i thought it was
they think that this is what we are they
think that america is a horrible place
and uh the military is just an aggressor
so
why would we why would we save those
people who helped us
where the people in uniform and the
people in the in in the real america and
that can be new york city los angeles
whatever but they have that feeling of
america
that's a loss of real honor and there is
something very very honorable uh in
america
and they don't have it they don't have
it and if the american people on the
democratic side and quite honestly
anybody else asleep
if they don't
find a place for that honor to reside in
them
um we are doomed
because this is the point of choosing it
really is the point of choosing you are
either going to go over the cliff with
the rest of humanity because you have to
you have to close your heart you can't
see this
and just leave your heart way open you
won't you'll bleed to death you have to
close your heart or do something to help
and
i i fear that many americans will now
just close their heart and that's why
dietrich bonhoeffer lost in germany
he was just like gandhi he did exactly
the same thing abraham lincoln
jesus all of them did
and he was unsuccessful in germany and
it's because the people had already
closed their heart we cannot let that
happen that's that's one of the main
reasons why
we're doing the nazarene fund and no
matter what anybody says
when we first started raising money for
the christians
it was because we thought everyone else
was going to get out
we are taking
we have taken
anyone who is marked for death i don't
care i've and dave i
uh i challenged uh glad who i know you
probably don't agree with um
fans of mine i know uh challenge glad i
challenge the national organization of
women
join me i don't agree with you
politically you don't agree with me
that's fine
but i i have religious friends who know
where the religious people are you gotta
know where some homosexual is hiding out
somebody has to hear
and have a friend i i have the planes we
have the resources let's go save them
nothing
nothing they don't care
okay so wait two things there first off
on the bonhoeffer story we discussed
that when i when you did my show a while
back so we're going to link to that so
if people want to know more about that
story because i think you're right he
was trying to do the right thing and
enough people said
nothing really works anymore i'm too
scared so that that's one thing just to
clarify what you're saying right now so
you reached out to glad national
organization for women said hey we want
to help anybody it's not just the
christians
you got no response
no response
no response so so okay so let's back up
quite honestly i mean if
if joe biden was stuck in afghanistan we
would get him and put him on a plane it
this is
this is the difference between the
collective uh thinking and the
individual
i think you have value
whoever you are
whatever your lifestyle whatever it is
you do you as a human being have value
and
and it i can't sit around why people
while people are
are are being
allowed to be executed burned
alive their tongues cut out no
my 12 year old daughter should not be
your wife should not be raped repeatedly
no my wife doesn't have to stay at home
what part of these things do you think
that you can't stand up for what
i just i really don't understand why
some people are just silent and they're
all just talking about politics this is
so far beyond politics yeah well in a
way it's a spiritual crisis and it's
this horrifically myopic view of the
world that views everything through that
political lens so if you're not with me
politically then sure i'm not going to
help glenn beck get the gays out of
afghanistan or get a woman who might be
raped out of afghanistan because glenn
beck is the real bad guy not not the
taliban but but wait i want to back up a
little bit because okay you guys have
raised 35 million dollars it's
absolutely incredible can you tell me a
little bit about the the uh original
mission of the nazarene fund and how
does this all happen i mean how do you
get planes there how do you secure the
area how do you make sure you're getting
the right people on the plane i mean
it's it's
extraordinary right yeah okay so so the
nazarene fund started um when they were
crucifying um christians and you
remember in iraq or syria they had
trapped all those yuzidis up on that
mountain yeah and they were surrounded
and no one would help that's the
beginning of the nazarene fund we're
like these people are all going to be
wiped out and nobody is helping them
nobody is helping them because the
yuzidis i mean i don't know of any city
families churches
groups anywhere but there yeah they were
literally like trapped at the top of a
mountain right it was just this small
correct correct so we went in to save
the yuzidis and also to save christians
because they were being crucified marked
for death so any religious minority
anywhere in america i mean
it kills me that we don't go for the
uyghurs in china
but anybody who is being persecuted for
their religious stance doesn't matter
what religion you are
we our mission is to go in and help you
and to get you to safety we have moved
i don't know the numbers dave so don't
hold me to any of these numbers i think
10 000 just to australia 10 000 people
or
it's i don't know the number i think it
may be more it's not less than that it's
maybe more than that um we have we've
gone in we've rescued them we have then
um stabilized them then brought them to
a host country we helped them learn a
language learn a trade we help them with
their rent
we help them with their food for over a
two year period so we don't just dump
people into a welfare system that
doesn't help them
and
this community in australia and several
other countries are are really thriving
now it's amazing to watch
um and so
just in the last two weeks though so so
you guys raise the funds you get the
planes there
how are you how are you making sure
you're getting the right people okay so
like the actual logistics of it so the
guy who is
my uh c o o of the nazarene fund
uh he is rudy atala and he is a guy who
is an air force
colonel or i don't know for 25 years he
was in the air force high ranking uh and
then he has been on i think two
presidents national security councils
he's a buttoned-up guy he is also
lebanese so he's he speaks arabic he um
he's from the middle east he understands
the whole culture
he's been just a rich rich asset for us
i called him on it was a tuesday night
and i said rudy we got it we got to get
out these people out
tell me
call me tomorrow morning and let's talk
about it on the air and give me a number
and so that's when he called me
wednesday morning and he is so good at
logistics and and uh
uh
dave i i can't tell you this uh
on camera
um but i i'm telling you
it was miracle
it was it was like active god stuff
because um
in the end and i'll tell you personally
and you can tell it later when it
becomes public knowledge but it's uh
there was that we went from not being
able to even land a plane
uh to
pretty much telling what planes
could be landed and and who's going
where and it just was a miracle so we
ended up being the group
that could get you out
with a plane
we we then uh partnered with others like
the mighty oaks foundation um
uh save our allies coalition i mean
there's like six different groups that
we have partnered with that their assets
were i can go in and get them but i
can't get them on a plane and so it was
this really cool thing where everybody's
just working together nobody cares about
the credit um you know nobody's
positioning in front of a camera it's
just let's go let's just go and help
yeah all right well i'm going to donate
of course and we're going to link to the
fund uh down below do you guys have a
sense of how many people
either americans i mean it's very
unclear to me at this point how many
americans are still there how many
christians are still there how many of
our translators and all of the other
people we were working with who are now
going to be targeted do we have any
sense of those numbers thousands
um you know let's just put it this way i
don't think anybody knows the american
number uh but it's not 300 or 200 it's
not even work close to that joe biden
came out and said in one press
conference at the beginning it was 16
then he said in the next press
conference you know a few days later
that it was ten thousand and then the
next press conference he said we got all
five thousand people out
now
i'm i'm not a mathematician but i don't
think 5000 is 10
or 15 000. maybe that's just me
well in joe's defense he doesn't really
know what he's saying so thank you
i'll grant him that much um all right
well before we wrap up i mean is there
is there anything else that you want to
share with my audience i mean obviously
again we're going to link to things and
all that but is there is there anything
else about this
you know it seems to me this is one of
those things which is why i'm so proud
to work with you and call you a friend
it's like this is what your life led to
is that you i know you're not just this
guy talking on these pipes like you are
actually trying to help people that's
why you know the history and why you're
why you're a student of history and i've
been to your house in your library and
the the documents that you have that
talk about that are the the items of
oppression over the years and the items
of freedom and all these things
um
is there anything else that you want to
share about this that i can
just yeah open the platform for i think
dave the most important thing and i i
think you get this because of our
conversations over the years and you
know i know people have thought for a
long time i think he's crazy he's just
bat crap crazy he's just a conspiracy
theorist
i'm telling you
this is the time i warned about this
these are the events and these are the
people in washington and around the
world that that i warned about
um
i said at one point this week because i
just
you know when you're doing this
and this is not my job i'm not a soldier
i'm not a guy who makes life and death
decisions
and uh and now i'm kind of in that and i
don't think i should that's not my skill
set and it wears on you it just wears on
you we got them but what about those
people did we get those people i
understand the ending of schindler's
list unlike i've ever understood it
and it is
um you mean that that last moment where
he's saying i could have done more i
could have done more could have
yeah
yeah um and but i i tell you that this
is the moment of choosing and p people
have to understand that that we are now
out of time and what i mean by that is
you don't need a revolution you don't
need anything you just need to realize
that you do have the power that you can
fix it we don't need washington to do it
i'm a recovering alcoholic former dj man
and
my group is flying planes out of the
middle east that's insane that's insane
you don't need permission and you are
not
the stooge of the government you are the
one with the power they convince the
australian people that oh no the
government's going to take care of you
and the government is great they're
building camps now
for the unvaccinated yes literally
i mean all you have to do is take away
guns that's all you have to do when the
i think it was washington said when the
uh government fears the people
there's freedom
when the people fear the government
there's oppression and i don't want them
to be like oh my gosh i'm afraid they're
going to blow us up i just want them to
know we know
we don't need them we don't need them
we'll make our own decisions back up
glenn
thanks for doing this thanks for
everything you do
have a good weekend i'm going to
continue on for a minute or two and
share a couple other things i'm you know
i'm trying to fight i'm trying to fight
for our friend larry elder here in
california it's a whole other a whole
other fight oh i know i've been
promoting my 10 days to now
and dave if you know
anyone any group in the middle east they
don't have to agree with us
if you know anyone i have been i think
you know this
i have been on the hey can we just pay
attention to the people they're throwing
off roofs in the middle east i've been
on that bandwagon for a long time
anything
anything to help
if you know of something that we can
help we're there
please i have no doubt my audience is
going to be reaching out to me to fill
me in on some stuff and as i said we're
going to link to all that
glenn thank you and thank you just keep
up the good work
god bless you thanks dude all right
uh okay guys so i hope that gave a
little bit of a sort of recap of
everything that's going on and and
i don't know i guess i suppose gave you
a little feeling that you have a little
power in this whether it's to donate a
little money or support support nazarene
fund however you can or just
really what glenn said there at the end
that this thing is kind of broken it's
very obvious i can tell you after being
off the grid for 30 days my feeling over
the last three days has been that
everything feels kind of broken right
now
but i don't feel broken and i'm guessing
that you don't feel completely broken
and that's what they're sort of preying
on that they can just break all of us
and we'll all just be dependent on them
forever and what glenn said there at the
end it's actually happening right now i
just saw an article about it right
before we started they are building
quarantine quarantine camps in australia
a population that does not have guns
it's like what is really going on here
can we not do anything
foreign policy wise that is right i mean
what will our allies think about us i
don't think we should have been we
probably never should have been at war
with afghanistan i remember the day we
went to war it was my i was at my
cousin's birthday party and i remember
one of the caterers was actually crying
because she was saying she just had just
heard that the that we were going to war
in afghanistan 20 years ago my same
cousin that i just went to her wedding a
few days ago she was like 12 or 13 at
the time um like what are our allies
gonna think now like oh is the united
states trustworthy whether the war was
right or wrong or anything else but
that's just sort of consistent with
everything that feels like it's breaking
down right now like our media is broken
down our political system is broken down
everyone feels like everyone's lying all
the time and i think the only thing that
we can do and again i am going to just
devote
every moment that i have to it is trying
to be honest and decent and figuring out
a way that that some of us can can make
it through this madness because the
madness ain't going anywhere so
uh as for the madness that's happening
here in california
there is a lot of momentum with larry
elder right now it's really feeling like
something
you know i tweeted out this morning i
have no doubt that california the
machine of california will will
do whatever it can to stop the recall
one way or another or make sure that
larry isn't the governor but maybe we
can overwhelm them with votes you know
what i mean like whatever they're going
to do actually david got an email last
night from the state of california
talking about mail and ballots and they
want everyone really to mail in because
they want you to do it safely now you
know me i'm a real right-wing freedom
extremist so i'm gonna vote in person
i'm gonna risk my life and vote in
person on the 14th um but one of the
things they said in the email
was that you can send in your ballot up
until the 14th now think about what that
means that means that if the election is
on the 14th and you can still send your
ballots in on the 14th then we know the
counting won't be done until the 14th so
do you think or till after the 14th so
do you think that perhaps if larry is in
the lead if the recall is happening do
you think maybe they're going to say oh
we got to wait because we got a whole
bunch of more uh mail-in ballots coming
you know it's like
everything is kind of screwy right now
but that's not a reason to give up right
like that's that's more of a reason to
fight than anything else so all of that
being said uh we are not doing an in
studio show on monday because larry
elder is doing an event where's the
event in thousand oaks right thousand
oaks california it's a little bit
outside of los angeles i'm going to go i
may speak it's a little unclear at the
moment but i'm going to be there with
the crowd we will live stream or post
some videos from there we're trying to
figure out some of the logistical stuff
and we'll see who some of the other
speakers are maybe i can do some
interviews or just talk to you guys or
something we are going to do something
because as i said i'm really devoting my
next 10 days to this maybe there's a
chance maybe there's a chance so that's
one thing on the other side we will link
to the nazarene fund down below i'm
going to donate right when we finish
this
and uh have a good weekend everybody
everything's gonna be okay i know it
feels nuts feels nuts guys am i being
positive and how do you feel today conor
gave me thumbs am i being positive or am
i giving a scary worldview are you
freaking out michael
they both gave me thumbs up all right
everything's gonna be all right but we
just but it's up to you i know who am i
to tell you everything's gonna be all
right i have no freaking clue but
it's up to you guys all right get out of
here have a good weekend